dream water nope that one was that one
that one was would we just say just this
very second Oh yummy
Oh Mads have you had a blu-ray before
yes you really have yes you cook it yep
yeah let me tell you nothing better than
having a gourmet meal at the comfort of
your own home with the freshest
ingredients freshest ingredients yeah
Organic code yo J yeah your woman do you
guys live together yes I don't know yeah
she lives with me and so does she cook
oh yeah she just cooked for me today she
did Oh amazing yeah butternut butternut
squash is that what it's called
yeah yeah she knows uh it was actually
in the squash and she baked it with goat
cheese on it oh my god yeah it was
amazing man yes sometimes if it's not
amazing do you say it Sam I say it's so
amazing every time every time even away
fits ah this is so good it's like [ __ ]
that's your [ __ ] you you're a correct
your spaghetti bolognaise I mean
everyone can cook I put carrots you do
just as a base you mean like a bear paw
we're how do you stood on carrots you
went down with celery and onion to make
a mirepoix honey listen I don't know
what me reply do please that mean they
boil it they just do it down to create
boil put carrots in my [ __ ] or what I do
with other stuff when I make you other
stuff like the not done and all that
stuff I make what else you may um I make
a lot of stuff for myself because I
could go off Filipino dishes and he
doesn't
he was like Filipino he doesn't like
good he doesn't like ya with a lot of
vinegar all the time so oh yeah
maybe he's not into it maybe you should
cook him some like real down-home
Filipinos caldereta
yeah I got would love to be like be no
go on dude I've had a little walk on and
my god huh all right it's all right
you're so angry I'm not angry
let me see something right you're so
angry that you have one tastes like
bulgogi and then it without loan or with
bone in a pot on fire are you part of
you accusing me of not having taste mmm
I have a plethora I have a plethora yeah
tell me what's uh let's be real that's
the taste rights of a third eye little
child real I like we see something okay
that's it yeah if there's Japanese food
I can do Chinese food you grew up with
Chinese food right and everyone there
were Korean I was forced to eat because
of my parents
no one ever cooked me Filipino food so
in my later days as an adult it's still
foreign to me the flavors although we go
to that bar byuklando we had his
birthday at the parks finest barbecue
fusion yeah it's more fusion it's
delicious it's the corn thing that they
have there is delicious their version of
a lot is already good too you know I um
I'm slowly you know I'm slowly trying to
get into Vietnamese shirt I didn't like
him at first because you know you didn't
like them who one of the food okay
slowly getting into Vietnamese but I
didn't really like them
that's a Buddha man as a people I love
the people the food yeah I love the
people are you kidding me of course you
love the people hey trans people are you
kidding me yeah they try to take you out
though did you try taking me mouth yeah
today
oh we were it uh no no I said um Alyssa
we he always uses the word jungle Asian
I can try to say come yeah bro jungle
ages and then next thing I know I had to
go to like news Vietnamese news and news
out like I was like in doing their news
I'm so sorry
well you know doing that also now he
just calls Filipinos jungle Asians
banana Filipinos don't care yeah yeah
because he's also half white no I mean
you called the old regime what does that
mean why do you what are you trying to
do with that because I'll tell you why
what are you why yeah okay Rob Schneider
says yeah I mean he's a full age you're
not full agen who's in a full Asia
Rob Schneider yeah he's happy support
who are you yeah so is this one but I'm
not any less Filipino because that's
what I subscribe to
you're not less Filipino you're less
Philip you're more Filipino than him
look we you your lady and I are more
Asian than you mmm-hmm I think you're
the whole Korean you is less Asian than
ya half of us if that makes any sense
yeah maybe I'm just being I'm being real
you are to what you're you're the
whitest Korean guy I know
Korean mana there I grew up in Green
Valley you're a banana and in Green
Valley in Poway where I grew up it was
all white people
okay sorry with all white people we had
a tennis court everything it was yeah I
had the country club no shooter yet a
dinner yeah and I was waiter hey Toby
and I would play hey Bobby are you gonna
play tennis today
yeah Parker I'll meet you out there you
know I mean killer yeah and so I grew up
with that life okay yeah but let me say
something right now in my early 20s and
as I got I know I started trying to [ __ ]
girls alright see you're gonna get in
trouble for that
Asians yeah no that's not what you said
that's how you're trying to lose
sponsors
but I was at work today and some guy
came up to me and said George is a pink
dick Wow
are you George yeah I can see that
though that's not funny to me
his face is pink yeah so when I work
yeah listen so Tiger belly yeah he was
like a high up guy yeah so we got to be
careful there's everywhere but he goes
holy I want to take back the [ __ ] flavor
stuff yeah I take that good [ __ ] all
that yeah
don't bleep it but you know we retire I
retract everything I've said today yeah
yeah yeah everything I've ever said
today
[Music]